but we're going to begin with this heat
making life difficult and even dangerous
nationwide and in europe as well in
cities including memphis washington and
new york it will feel like triple digits
yikes excessive heat warnings and alerts
are in place across much of the country
today the heat is also contributing to
life-threatening fires overseas at a
level that has rarely been seen before
we're covering all the angles of this
story but we're going to begin with you
chris van cleeve in dallas where the
temperatures could top 110 today and
that would set a new record chris good
morning to you i can't even begin to
understand what 110 degrees is going to
feel like what's your prediction of what
it what what it will feel like today
gail if this breeze continues it's going
to feel like you're standing inside of a
hair dryer now north texas is waking up
yet again
under an excessive heat warning think
about this we are less than a month into
summer already the dallas area has seen
today included 24 100
or higher days that's more than many
summers see for the entire season
an intense heat fueled wildfire burned a
number of homes as temperatures reached
111 degrees west of dallas monday
forcing mandatory evacuations near
possum kingdom lake we have a pretty
significant drought all across north and
central texas this drought caused us to
go into summer much earlier than we
normally see and it's not just texas
nearly 40 million people in parts of
california arizona and the central
plains are facing dangerous temperatures
that just won't quit is this a example
of climate change impacting the the
weather pattern we're certainly seeing
more extreme weather due to climate
change we're also seeing a repeat of
patterns like la nina the national
weather service says la nina is like a
vicious cycle driving warmer and drier
conditions north which creates a drought
that in turn prompts more hot
temperatures getting the weather pattern
stuck in a heat dome hopefully it cools
off soon i'm tired of it i don't like i
don't like when it's too hot like this
ercot the operator of the texas power
grid continues pleading with customers
to reduce electricity hoping to avoid
rolling blackouts this month official
numbers are still coming in but demand
for electricity over the last three
months is on track to set dozens of
records and he is currently on a call
paramedics in fort worth say they are
currently treating more than double the
number of patients suffering heat
related illnesses compared to last year
what happened to you i got dizzy
and fell down
do you think the heat played into you
getting dizzy it's pretty hot out yeah
i'm yeah i'm 65 years old
extreme heat can be deadly and it's
going to be extremely hot here whether
it hits 110 or not it will still be
the hottest day dallas has seen in about
five years and just a couple of degrees
away from the hottest dallas has ever
seen that was 113. the national weather
service is urging people to stay
hydrated and limit their time outdoors
as this heat can become dangerous very
quickly vlad
that is a key message to stay hydrated
thank you very much chris appreciate it